[Musique]
parlons de léon morin prêtre ce
personnage effectivement je pense que la
majorité des gens ne vous voit pas nom
d'un prêtre voulant plus peut-être aux
normes au départ je veux dire que tu te
rends quand jean pierre melville est
venu à rome me proposait aller ans mort
après j'étais un peu affolés à l'idée
met une soutane et de représenter après
parce que vraiment je ne me voyais pas
là dedans et jean pierre m'a donné des
arguments qui m'ont convaincu et je
regrette pas du tout d'avoir fait
chanter vous la sensation d'avoir appris
quelque chose en jouant ce rôle très
différent de ceux dans lequel on vous
voit habituellement
ah oui je prends du temps déroule comme
ça que l'on peut progresser en tant
qu'acteur en jouant un rôle qui n'était
pas a priori au départ enfin le dire
dans ma nature est vraiment j'ai appris
là et j'ai trouvé des choses que je ne
savais pas qui était en moi elle est à
peu près temps c'est de faire ça non
mais au contraire cela vous a fait
plaisir et ça fait très plaisir je pense
ça m'a ouvert une voie je croise jean
vient belleville pourquoi vous vous avez
choisi belmondo pour tenir le rôle de
léon morin prêtre nous savons vous
n'avez pas l'habitude de faire des films
disons commerciaux et que ce n'est donc
peut-être pas par sa valeur commerciale
que vous aurez choisi
donc j'ai choisi jean paul belmondo
avant qu'il soit une ville est consacré
à l'époque qu'il était en train de
tourné à bout de souffle et la première
fois j'ai rencontré jean paul belmondo
stato l'aérodrome d'orly nous sommes
croisés dans un escalier nous sommes
serré la main et je me suis dit tiens il
a la gueule qu'il faudrait pour faire
les sommes en jeu ne savait pas encore
du tout quel genre de comédien de cinéma
certaine je savais bien eu deux trois
fois l'an des choses sans importance
veut dire qu'une fois que vous le
souffle est sorti on savait tous a
présenté sur la valeur artistique
le professionnel de jean pas le il y
avait très longtemps que j'avais envie
de tourner les en aura plus de huit ans
et tous les ans d afrique ce bac
l'auteur on veut téléphoner ensemble
n'avaient toujours pas trouvé les
comédiens que vous voulez je disais non
et couche sur coup j'ai eu envie de
prendre les manettes d'un projet de
barney puis quand j'ai connu jean paul
réactions se posait même pas c'était
jean paul belmondo qu'il fallait prendre
pour faire léon morin et personne
d'autre pourquoi il n'existe pas un
france benjamines manger peut être même
notre acteur que belmondo aux états unis
incontestablement si je crois que jean
paul tu m'en veux pas que ce jeudi férié
aux états unis des comédiens
remarquables et de ta valeur je dois
dire qu'en france il très difficile de
trouver un homme entre 25 et 30 ans qui
soit à la fois totalement viril qui
puisse jouer et le p'tit métallo de chez
renault
le prêtre intellectuelle de lyon morin
le prêtre intellectuelle mais
montagnards d'origine paysanne et bien
jusqu'à présent nous avons beaucoup
parlé de belmondo parlons maintenant
effectivement du personnage de léo morin
de lyon aura lui même
vous l'avez fait en collaboration avec
béatrice beck parce que tout à l'heure
vous parliez béatrice beck dans le choix
est tellement d'eau n'ont jamais
aviation est finie quand je n'ai pas
travaillé avec béatrix beck pour
l'adaptation je crois que c'est un
mauvais système je te faire appel à
l'auteur à lire conférer datation
l'auteur a tout dit
si on lui demande de faire l'adaptation
de son livre il le trail obligatoirement
il a envie d'écrire une autre histoire
donc vous l'avez fait sans béatrice beck
mais béatrice beck a vu elle un fils
maintenant comment ça vient du mont très
belles choses réponse qui va faire ce
plaisir
10 je me suis retenu pendant deux heures
j'ai serré les mâchoires pour ne pas
claquer des dents j'essaierai mes jambes
pour que mes genoux le centre choque pas
j'ai retrouvé dans certaines scènes le
sentiment que la caméra avait été caché
à l'époque les classes elle a été capté
[Musique]